from a middle eastern battlefield to a
european one syrian soldiers are being
asked to join russia's fight in ukraine
we sacrifice our blood and soul for you
syria for you bashar is their call to
arms on the ban as it reads the great
russian army we will defeat the nazis
this is from the social media channel of
russia's defense ministry
and russia's president says they're
welcome to come to donbass that's in
eastern ukraine where russian-backed
separatists from donetsk and lugansk are
fighting government forces
in response to reports of foreign
fighters joining ukraine's army the
russian government says it too has had
requests from all over the world to join
the battle
regarding the gathering of soldiers from
around the world for ukraine we see them
the western sponsors of the ukrainian
regime do not keep it secret they do it
openly disregarding international law so
if you see people who want voluntarily
without payment to come and help people
in dumbass well we need to meet their
efforts and help them reach the combat
zone on the talks of ukraine the most
recent were on thursday in turkey putin
says his negotiators tell him there are
certain positive shifts
he was talking to bella russian
president alexander lukashenko who's in
moscow
lukashenko has given russia troops and
access to its territory to help the
invasion of ukraine it's brought belarus
a similar level of sanctions as russia
faces
we have been overcoming these sanctions
for as long as you'd like we have to
build back our economy we can do without
them we have everything to live and work
normally but life in russia is not
normal at the moment as a further
threatened crackdown on social media
highlights
facebook says it's relaxing its hate
speech rules in relation to russia's
invasion of ukraine so prosecutors here
want parent company meta declared an
extremist organization and facebook and
instagram to be blocked criminal cases
have also been opened into meta staff
though none are based here as the
company has long resisted demands to
open an office in russia
bernard smith al jazeera moscow